c'est l'histoire d'un pari un peu fou
relier bordeaux à lyon par une ligne de
chemin de fer sans forcément passer par
la case paris un trajet aujourd'hui
impossible depuis l'abandon de la ligne
par la sncf en 2014
mais ce pari rail cup est en passe de le
gagner
cette coopérative ferroviaire compte
aujourd'hui plus de 8000 sociétaires et
a réussi à réunir un capital social d'un
5 millions d'euros budget minimum pour
décrocher une licence ferroviaire alain
est l'un des sociétaires de rail cup
après avoir passé des années à se
lamenter devant les fermetures de lignes
dans les territoires il a décidé de
rejoindre l' aventure cette aventure
c'est de remettre du train là où il y en
a plus la ligne bordeaux lyon qui va
être la première ligne cry coop va
ouvrir mais j'ai appris quelques jours
en relisant impérieux du document que
lagarde ghana qui est sur la ligne va
réouvrir réouvrir parce que raï coop s'y
installe donc voilà ça c'est formidable
parce que c'est très facile à l'est de
bordeaux à paris de bordeaux en charente
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et de
bordeaux dans le massif central c'est
quasiment impossible
quasiment impossible à la donc cette
aventure c'est remettre du train là où
il y en a plus et remettent de la
dynamique dans ces territoires qui ont
été un peu abandonné le train c'est une
manière de les faire revivre
je suis convaincu qu'on va avoir un
renouveau du train convaincu oui et donc
là bas c'était l'occasion de participer
ce renouveau un renouveau qui devrait
donc débuter en 2022
avec l'ouverture par rail cup de la
ligne bordeaux lyon
une dizaine de gars devraient être
desservis parmi elles libourne limoges
ou encore montluçon aujourd'hui 90% des
français résiste à moins de 10
kilomètres d'une gare mais 30% de ses
gares existantes ne sont plus desservis
la sncf de son côté privilégie les axes
paris province
pour le directeur général de rail cup il
s'agit d'offrir aux territoires de
nouvelles opportunités en jeu de rail
cup c'est effectivement de 2
de reconnecter un certain nombre de
territoires parce que le ferroviaire est
un élément essentiel en fait de
l'attractivité des territoires le
développement économique des territoires
à l'attractivité du territoire nécessite
effectivement que ces territoires soient
connectés au ferroviaire et donc si on
veut avoir un développement un
aménagement du territoire qui soit
équilibrée et bien il faut un maillage
ferroviaire ça c'est l'un des premiers
l'une des premières motivations de la
coop et la deuxième motivation de rail
cup c'est effectivement de répondre à
cet enjeu très fort en ce moment qui est
la transition écologique donc de
permettre à un certain nombre de
territoires d'accéder à cette mobilité
décarbonée
quel ferroviaire la coopérative le son
adn c'est pas simplement de faire du
ferroviaire pour faire du ferroviaire
mais cette fleur du ferroviaire pour
servir les territoires et servir la
transition écologique rail cup ne compte
pas s'arrêter sur de si bons rails
cette année déjà la coopérative devrait
ouvrir sa première ligne de fret
s'en suivront deux autres lignes pour
les particuliers rennes toulouse et lyon
thionville ouverture prévue en 2023